neo is much more than just Dark Souls  with samurai but it will be using  another staple of From Software's games  I'm Tony and this GameSpot news update  challenges you to a duel  neo will feature a PvP mode but not at  launch team ninja will introduce the  feature later in a free update details  of this PvP motor scarce but director  yusuke hayashi cites Dark Souls as a  direct influence and the type of fan he  wants the mode to appeal to  he's also quick to point out that this  is not a last-minute addition to the  game in fact enemies move the way they  do because the team always had PvP in  mind neo launches exclusively on ps4 On  February 9th  the base game already lets you choose  between an improved framerate or  resolution and the ps4 pro patch will  take those modes even further for all  the latest on neo you're already in the  right place  you